je vous demande
oui quelle est la vedette de music hall
qui dans vraiment de tout le temps tu
que nous avons fait la joie de 10 ha a
vraiment eu régulièrement un succès
considérable qui a été une amie la plus
fidèle qui nous a parlé du plus loin
possible
est-ce que vous moi pendriez qu'il
s'agit de et 10 kg à edith piaf vial
souvient
j'avais dit avant avant de vous demander
de nous chanter votre l'une de vos
dernières créations puisque la dernière
fois vous êtes venue dans l'émission
vous ne pouviez pas encore déchanter est
ce que je peux vous demander quel a été
votre plus récente joie de vivre
pas celle que j'ai fait avec toi non non
non non non non non non la plus récente
dans votre vie enfin l'oeuvre la plus
grande joie que vous ayez eu depuis
votre retour en france
c'est ma rentrée le lundi à c'est le
contact avec le public rit même ça a été
plus fort que jamais oui est-ce que
c'était plus fort que le carnegie hall à
new york
aso pour la même chose où il s'est
évidemment c'est à nous c'est un autre
genre de succès en ont depuis je peux
pas rentrer dans les détails puisque je
vais vexés les américains s'est défendu
alors et vous donne les clés personne et
vous allez nous chanter une chanson qui
je crois vous avez rapport à mener
d'amérique alors comme ça ça fait le
mélange
elle met dans une situation notamment
d'arranger les choses comme ça quelle
chanson de jean dréjac l'homme à la moto
il portait des culottes des parcs de
moto un trousseau de cuir noir avec un
aigle sur le don ça montre qu'ils
partaient comme un boulet de canon se
mêle à terre entre la rue
jamais il ne se voit pas et jamais il ne
se lavait les onglets plein de comprimés
sur la liste même s'il avait un tatouage
avec un câble sur la problème est juste
à l'intérieur on lisait moment je t'aime
il avait une petite amie du nom de marie
lou ont la peau nette en pitié
une enfant de son âge car tout le monde
savait bien qu'il aime et on tord le cou
sa chienne de motos bignone avantage il
portait des culottes heures des côtes de
motos 1 pouces ou de cuir noir avec un
aigle sous la dent ça montre qu'ils
partaient comme un boulet de canon semer
la terreur dans toute la rue
elle a imploré le supplia et je ne parle
pas ce soir je vais pleurer si tu t'en
vas
mais les mots furent et faire du sel de
par le rayonnement dans le bruit de la
machine est dit qu il y avait des
flammes dans les yeux
vos passages à niveau ce fut comme un
éclair de feu contre une alternative qui
filait vers midi
et quand on démarre à salé d'evry on
trouve à 5 eu l'honneur ces pop tout de
cuir noir avec intègre sous la barre
mais plus rien de la banque aurait pu
rien de ce témoin qui se met la terreur
dans poupe